- Hello all, and welcome to
Khan Academy for Parents,
6th through 8th Grade
Remote Learning Webinar.
I'm Meaghan Pattani,
I lead US Professional
Learning here at Khan Academy
and I'm joined today by two
of my wonderful colleagues,
Roy Chan, who's a member
of our US District
Partnership Team, and
he works with teachers
and communities all over the US,
and Dan Tieu, who's our
director of marketing,
and he's also working with
families and communities
to help instill best
practices for remote learning.
What we'll cover today is how you can keep
your children learning
during school closures,
and some best tips and
practices for setting up
a daily schedule for
students to use Khan Academy.
One note of what we
won't be covering today
is account setup, or how to get started.
This webinar is not gonna
walk through how to set up
an account for you, or for your student.
So if you're looking for more information
on how to get started with Khan Academy,
please see our Remote
Learning Quickstart Guide.
And these slides and all of the resources
that go along with them
can be found in the handout
on the right hand side of
your GoToWebinar panel.
Just as a quick note that
Khan Academy is free,
trusted, and flexible.
We're a nonprofit with
a mission to provide
a free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
We have standards-aligned
practice and lessons covering
K through 12 math, grammar,
science, computer programming,
history, AP courses,
official SAT practice,
and a lot more.
And your students are
able to learn on the web
or on our app through iOS or Android,
at anytime, anywhere,
in over 40 languages.
So what type of content is available?
In addition to full coverage for math,
our content library also includes things
like American history, computer
animation and programming,
grammar, Growth Mindset, which
is built in collaboration
with PERTS at Stanford,
high school biology, and
storytelling which is created
in partnership with Disney and Pixar.
So where would students find content?
Or where would you find content?
By clicking the left-hand courses menu
on the top left of the Khan Academy site.
You'll have access to
our entire content menu.
Or, you can select edit courses
from the student's
homepage to access content
and then click continue.
The content that's originally
suggested to your student
will be based off the
grade level they selected
when they set up their account.
So let's talk a little
bit about daily schedules
for 6th through 8th graders.
Khan Academy has been sharing
schools closure schedule
for students across grade levels,
but we're gonna be focusing
on what we think of
as a middle school range in the US,
our sixth through eighth grade students.
And here's a quick overview
of what we recommend.
The areas covered in green
are gonna be the areas
that we focus on a little
bit more during this webinar.
These are what we think of
as academic areas in the day.
So starting in the morning, we recommend
that students get up, get dressed,
yes, actually get out of their PJ's,
and then focus on their math skills.
One of the reasons we recommend that
is that students and teachers have said
they feel like their
brain is ready to work
and that they're energized
and able to work on math
more effectively in the morning.
Now, definitely feel
free to adapt this to you
or to your students, but
again, this is a recommendation
from many of our teachers and students
that they feel like the
morning is the best time
for them to focus on math.
And based on your child
or student's grade level,
we recommend one of the
following math courses
as a good place to start.
Sixth, seventh, or eighth grade math,
Algebra 1, or geometry.
If you feel like your
student, you're not quite sure
where they should start,
and you want to put them,
on grade level, but you
know that they already know
some of the material, they
can use course challenges
and unit tests to accelerate
through material quickly.
All of our math content
is mastery-enabled,
and it covers standards from kindergarten
through early college.
It includes instant feedback,
step-by-step solutions
like you're seeing on
the screen right now,
that students can select a hint
and see a step-by-step
work-through of that exact problem,
but also offers instruction in the form
of videos and articles.
Practice for single skill
in the form of exercises,
or assessments in the form
of quizzes, unit tests,
and course challenges,
all the while tracking
progress at the skill,
unit, and course level for students.
After math time, we
recommend students get out
and go for a walk or run.
If the weather is bad, try
something like JustDance.
Find a reason to get up and get moving.
Then maybe take some time to read.
Khan Academy has compiled a list of books
for the sixth through eighth graders.
If you click on that link,
you'll see specifically
what those recommendations are
from our teachering community.
Again, take a short break.
It's really easy for
students to get caught up
in wanting to do all
the work that they have,
but it's important that students
get up from their screens
and are able to move around.
Then we recommend jumping into
some English language arts.
While we have a full grammar
course, and it may say
third through fifth grade on the content,
we've seen students from
kindergarten through high school
benefit from working
on our grammar course.
If maybe that doesn't
appeal to your student,
try our storytelling course.
Our grammar course, like our math courses,
is mastery-enabled.
It covers over 100 grammar skills,
and similar to our math courses,
it has instant feedback,
step-by-step solution,
instruction in the form
of videos and articles,
practice, and assessments.
Similar to our math courses,
if you feel that your student
is able to accelerate quickly
through some of the material,
have them engage with unit
tests and course challenges,
and they'll be able to move
through that material quickly
and then focus their time
on skills they may need
more practice with.
We also have some new beta content for ELA
which covers standards in
second through eighth grade
reading and vocabulary.
What this means is this
is an early version
of some new content that's
coming for each grade level,
and it's broken out for
second, third, fourth,
fifth, sixth, seventh, and eighth grade.
So you can have your
student practice on specific
grade level appropriate questions,
including instant feedback,
and work rationales
for every question.
And the passage topics
are grade-appropriate
in areas of science, social studies,
and social-emotional learning.
To supplement our ELA content,
students are also encouraged
to engage with our
Imagineering in a Box course,
which is created in
partnership with Disney.
This allows for project-based learning,
and for students to get
a little more creative.
It includes things like
a behind-the-scenes look
at how artists, designers, and engineers
work together to create Disney parks.
It includes instruction
aspects of videos and articles,
and project-based activities
to design their own theme park.
After lunch, we recommend
that students engage
in some science and or social studies.
Our science courses allow
students to look at things
like what is a virus, and
how might the human body
respond to that?
Or look at our history courses
to align maybe some historical aspects
that align with things that
are currently happening
in the news, or how
countries are responding
to the pandemic.
Our high school biology
course, like our math
and grammar course, is mastery-enabled,
covering introductory level biology topics
including areas that are
middle school-age appropriate.
It includes instant
feedback and work rationale
for every question, instruction
in the form of videos
and articles, practice
exercises, and assessments
in terms of quizzes, unit
tests, and course challenges.
Our US history course
is also mastery-enabled.
Excuse me.
It includes instant feedback,
instruction, and practice,
just like our other
mastery-enabled courses.
In the very end of the afternoon,
what students would think
of as the normal end
to their school day, we
encourage students to engage
in some enrichment content,
things like maybe Code.org Express course,
or Khan Academy's computer programming,
or our Growth Mindset content.
Our computer animation course
is an interactive course
that demonstrates how
traditional school subjects
such as math, science, and the arts,
the a vital part of everyday work
put into Pixar's filmmaking process.
For many students, this
answers the question
of why am I doing this?
And our interactive units
range from the art of lighting
to set and staging, so it
allows students to apply
the concepts that they're
learning in their academic courses
into something in the real world.
Again, they receive instant
feedback, step-by-step solution,
instruction, and practice.
Finally, our growth
mindset content provides
a structured way for
students to explore the idea
that they in fact can learn anything.
It includes units on
the brain and learning,
working through frustration,
and making and learning
from mistakes, and setting goals.
It includes instruction
in the form of videos
and articles for students,
and also includes teacher resources
that you as a parent can use
to help guide your student
through these growth mindset activities.
If you're looking for more
tips and best practices
for remote learning, we
also have some resources
around seven tips for
effective remote learning
to help support students,
teachers, and parents
during this time.
Now, we know many of you have questions,
and we're going to take the time now
to go through those questions,
as I hand it over to Dan.
But please feel free, that if
we don't get to your question,
or if you have additional
ones, to reach out
to our help center, where we have answers
to frequently asked questions,
as well as a community space.
- Thank you, Meaghan.
Hi everyone, I'm Dan,
and I'll be moderating the
live portion of this Q and A,
and I wanted to give a shoutout to Roy
for manning the submitted questions.
Before we get into the live
section, as Meaghan said,
we have a limited amount of
time, so we're not gonna get
to everybody, but rest
assured, afterwards,
the team does look over the questions,
and we try to surface the
ones that are really important
and that are frequently
asked, and we do update
those documents as we go along.
So the two steps we'd asked you to follow
before we go to the live question portion
is first go to the handout
section of this presentation
and grab the download.
It contains guidance to
everything that Meaghan
just walked through, between an overview
of the available content
for middle schoolers
to the suggested schedules
and the framework,
and you can always modify
those to meet your needs,
as well as many of you
have seen links throughout
the presentation, and so you'll have links
to all those resources as well.
And then a second thing I'd ask,
if you have any questions please put them
in the question box now,
and I'll do the facilitating
while Meaghan actually does the hard work
of answering the questions.
So we have quite a few
questions already coming in.
We have one that actually
I can answer first,
which is, "Is the suggested reading list
"available on the site someplace?"
So, right now in the daily schedules
we do have some lists
of recommended books.
We are early next week
gonna have a separate page
with an updated reading
list organized by category.
So come back on probably
Tuesday or Wednesday,
and we'll have that available for you all.
So Meaghan, we have a
question from Jacqueline
who asks, "What does
mastery-enabled course content
"mean on slide two?"
I think that's a fantastic question,
and we get that question a lot.
- Yeah, thanks Dan.
Jacqueline, that is a
really common question,
and a really important one.
So bear with me, this is gonna
take a minute to go over.
So when we think about Khan Academy
and the way we encourage
students to learn,
we're really founded in the
principles of mastery learning,
that students learn at
their own time and pace
if given the right content
that fits their needs
and so that students can fill in gaps
in areas that they might
have struggled with
or missed learning in the past,
and can also accelerate ahead to areas
that they're really strong in.
And so because Khan Academy
is founded in this belief
of mastery learning, our courses
that are mastery-enabled,
and we're working to bring
even more of our courses
to be what we call mastery-enabled,
it allows students to see
specifically how they're doing
in each individual skill, the
unit, and the entire course.
By using those practice
exercises and assessments
in the form of quizzes,
tests, and course challenges,
students move from not
started, to attempted,
to familiar, to proficient, and mastered.
And all those levels mean
is how well the student
is demonstrating their understanding
of an individual skill.
And so for students to achieve
those high levels of mastery,
they have to be able to
demonstrate their understanding
of a skill in multiple ways.
And so when we say a
course is mastery-enabled,
it means it has all of these
pieces that allows a student
to learn at their own
pace, and to demonstrate
their understanding so that
they are able to understand
areas where they may need more support,
or areas where they're
ready to move ahead.
- Great.
So Meaghan, this is pretty related.
So a question from Yvette
asks, "If my children are
"in a GATE program, a gifted
and talented education program,
"how would I determine which
courses are best for them?"
And I think this is a
question whether your child
is in an advanced state, or if your child
needs some remediation
in a specific subject.
I think it's relevant
for multiple audiences.
- Yeah, you're absolutely right.
And this is a question we
get obviously for gifted
and talented students, but
I think for all students,
parents, you're being asked
a really tough challenge right now.
Where does my student start at the moment?
This has been student that
your teachers have been
working with your students
all year, but now you're
kind of dropped into the middle.
And so our first recommendation
is look for guidance from teachers.
If the teachers have
provided specific guidance
or where the student
might already be working,
definitely leverage that.
So if you know your student
is in an algebra course
and they're part of the way through,
we would recommend looking
at the algebra course
and then taking the course challenge,
and what the student does
is they get a mixed review
of questions, and it'll
highlight very quickly
areas for the student to
work on, and areas that they
already know the content.
If you don't have a good idea
where your student might be
based on either feedback from the teacher
or the course they're registered for
then you can either A, look
at something like grade level
content, so our courses
for math in particular
are broken out by grade level,
so if you had a sixth grade
student, we might recommend
that you start them on sixth grade,
or you can start them a grade behind
if you feel like you
know that there's a lot
of gaps for them.
The other alternative is to
look at some of our courses
that cover a couple
different grade levels,
so things like arithmetic
cover multiple grade levels
and give students a better
idea of where they might fall.
But again, I would circle back
to if you have recommendations
from your teacher,
they know your students really well,
so I would start there, and
then recommend on grade level.
If you feel like your
student needs to step back
or move ahead, again, they
can use those components
of the course itself to
either spend more time
on specific learning,
using videos and articles,
and then engaging with the
practice, or if you feel
like they're really strong,
they can accelerate quickly
by using the unit tests
or the course challenges.
- And I would just add,
Meaghan, that it doesn't hurt
to review materials that your
child is already proficient in
and in fact, one of our teacher educators,
Tim Vandenberg, recommends for his class,
he starts everyone at kindergarten level
and just have them quickly
roll through the course
and really hit there so
that they can progress
and fill in the Swiss
cheese gaps that they have,
and so everyone really
learns at their own pace.
- That's great, Dan.
And what we find with teachers,
and we think at the beginning of the year,
we often encourage them to
engage with something similar
so that students can build
confidence in using Khan Academy
with something they already
know before they get
into challenging material.
So I think it's a really
great recommendation, Dan.
- So Meaghan, we have
a question from Matilda
who asks, "For the math
program do you recommend
"the students start with
the unit test or quiz
"before they do the
practice first, just to see
"what they already know, or
to start from top to bottom,
"but doing the practices
and going down the list?"
- Sure, I think it's a
little bit of preference.
Some students really prefer
to build up their confidence
with the individual
skills first, and then go
to the unit test because
the unit test will cover
all the skills in the
unit, and that can be
really intimidating for students.
However, in this unique situation
that we're in right now,
if you're not sure where to
start with your students,
or they think they might know part of it,
then if you're not sure where
the student should start,
I would recommend starting
with the course challenge
or the unit test, so to
help the student identify
what they should focus on.
If they already know what
unit they're working in,
they I might recommend
going from top to bottom
because it's designed for
students to build confidence
and build skills on top of
each other so that they feel
really confident and
can make great progress.
- Great.
And so Meaghan, these
next series of questions,
one from Lily and one from
Meeta, I think all parents
are asking this question,
it's really around
how much parental assistance
would you recommend
or would you say is
required to help your child
through these courses?
- So, I think that's a
really tough question.
So first of all, we all
know you're doing double
or triple duty right now,
being a full-time parent
and a full-time employee
and now a full-time teacher.
So, one, we're definitely
not expecting you
to know all of the content
for your student's math course
or science course or computer programming,
whatever it is they're
using Khan Academy for.
We do find if you want a
little more content knowledge,
we're finding a lot of parents find it
really challenging and
exciting to learn alongside
their student, and I was a
classroom teacher for nine years
and I can say that one of
the most exciting things
for my students was to
admit, you know what?
I don't know the answer to that.
Why don't we work through it together?
So if you're looking to give support,
don't be afraid to
engage with your students
and say, you know what?
I don't remember how
to multiply fractions.
That's totally fine.
It gives you an opportunity to show them
you never stop learning, and
something to learn with them.
The idea with the schedule I
think to address that question
a little more directly, is
the schedules are designed
to help the students stay
on pace, but they're still
gonna need support from someone else,
and so Khan Academy,
while a wonderful tool,
is not meant to replace
the teacher entirely.
And so we do recommend
that there is some support
given to the student as
they work through this,
so if you can encourage
your student to work
within that schedule, or maybe take time
to discuss the reading
you're doing together
and maybe some of that
recommended reading,
so it is meant to be used
with a parent or guardian
or some sort of supporting
figure along with them.
Though we would think at
the middle school age level
they would be able to
follow a great majority
of this by themselves.
- Yeah, and I would just
add onto that, Meaghan,
I think where you as parents
are particularly useful
in this case is to help provide
structure for your learners.
I don't think, it's been
a while since I've done
any geometry or algebra, so
it's not like we expect you
to remember how to do
differential equations
off the top of your head.
I think it's more about
helping the schedule
and helping to motivate your child,
and providing that level of a support
versus actual subject expertise.
- Excellent.
- So Meaghan, we have a
question around, from Diane,
"Would you mind sharing where we can find
"the course challenge in order to identify
"where the learning
gaps and successes are?"
- Sure, no problem.
So I'm actually going to
move over to the Khan Academy site,
and I believe you all should
be able to see my screen
in just a minute, and so I think this is
a really important question,
because we do often
offer this as guidance.
If you don't know where
your student should start
they can take the course challenge.
And so let's take Algebra 1, for example.
If I'm a student and I select courses
in the top left of my site,
I can see all the courses
that are available
to me as a student.
And let's say I'm going to take Algebra 1,
and I choose Algebra 1
from the course list.
This will bring me to the
course page for algebra
and shows me all of the
content that's available.
If I scroll all the way down
to the bottom of the page,
you'll see this box that
says course challenge.
And here, if I click
start course challenge,
it'll pop up with, excuse me, 30 questions
that are on skills throughout the course.
And so here I'll be
offered, again, 30 questions
that cover a variety of skills throughout
the entire course.
We do expect this to take most students
30 to 45 minutes to
complete, so if this is where
you feel like is the best place
for your student to start,
make sure they have enough time to do so,
and I would also recommend that
they have a couple of tools
with them, things like pencil
and paper, or a whiteboard,
because they're probably
gonna need some space
to work through those problems.
And then once they complete
the course challenge,
it'll show them in their
results some skills
that they're really strong
with, and some skills
where they might need some more support.
And what will happen in the course itself
is they'll have indicators
with little sparkly star marks
of areas for them to
focus on, so students know
after they take the course challenge,
within Khan Academy itself, they'll know
where to focus their time.
- Great.
So here's a question that
actually I can answer,
so question from Lauren,
and the question is, "How
should I use the supplement,
"and what," I guess, "How should
I use this as a supplement
"to what our school district is giving?"
And in terms of how do use this, sorry,
we created these schedules
early on in this process
before others were made
available, and so we were
really trying to fill a void
that we saw existed out there.
We would say, recommend that you defer
to your school district's
recommendations first,
and actually really modify
this to fit your needs as well,
so if there are gaps that
you feel like you want
your child to follow, do that.
But this, by no means,
is meant to override
what your school district
or your school is advising.
Great question though.
So Meaghan, we have a
question from Vivian who asks,
Hi, I'm the mother of an
eighth grader who's quarantined
"at home right now.
"I'd like to know what
good strategies I can use
"to help my child stay
motivated in learning.
"She's sloppy with her schoolwork,
"because most of the
assignments is not mandatory."
- Yeah, I think this is
something that is not exclusive
to parents right now.
We're seeing this with
a lot of our teachers.
First of all, middle school is really hard
and it's hard to keep students motivated
even in the classroom,
let alone now that they're
working remotely, and that
you as a parent are trying
to instill in them the
commitment to still learning
when they're not in the
physical brick and mortar space.
And so some things we're
finding are motivating
with students either sharing
maybe that connection
to what things that they're learning are
to greater things in life,
so in some of our careers,
or in some of the engineering resources,
showcasing connections for students.
One of the more external
ones that we're finding,
teachers are doing this,
but I think it's applicable
to anyone, is that finding
ways to motivate their students
in things like doing challenges,
or little fun videos,
or fun activities, that maybe are outside
even your own comfort zone to get students
and say if you're willing
to make 10% progress
in seventh grade math, if
you make that progress,
I as your parent will let you
paint my fingernails green,
or things that you can't necessarily buy
but might be really funny.
So we've seen a teacher, for
example, do the TikTok flip
where their daughter
was putting on makeup,
and then he changes and he's
putting on the makeup instead,
so just funny little things
that again are really appealing
to your student or your
child, but again it's not
necessarily bribery, per
se, but student that's
really creative, or something
that might engage them
to say I'm putting in this
effort, and you're putting in
the effort with me to do so
the other thing that I'll circle back to
that we talked about earlier
that we find is motivating
for students is someone willing
to learn alongside them,
so again, that idea that we
definitely wouldn't expect you
to remember all of your
geometry or seventh grade math,
but that you're open with
your student in saying
why don't we learn this together?
Why don't we go back and
learn something together?
Or, if you learn your
math, maybe we'll sit down
and try this intro to
JavaScript class together,
and learn something new together?
So making it something that you are doing
as a family as opposed to
something that the student
has to do in isolation.
- Great.
We have two questions
that are kind of related
around the breadth and
extent of our content.
So Debra asks, "Do your
grade level classes cover
"an entire year's worth of questions?"
And then kind of related
to that, Marci's asking
once their child completes
all of the eighth grade
course challenges, will
Khan Academy automatically
move them up to the next level?
- So when we talk about breadth
and depth of our content,
we do most of the courses are
expected to take a full year.
So if you're looking
at a full math course,
like sixth, seventh, or eighth grade math,
that is expected to
cover all of the skills,
or the great majority of
skills, that are in that course
according to common
course state standards,
so all of our courses are common course
state standard aligned,
and the breadth of that
is what is expected for
that course completion.
So the answer to that is
yes, it's supposed to take
that long, and we have
teachers work on things
like setting a goal for
students on what they would
expect to complete for the
year, we expect them getting
to 80 or 90% of mastery
would be what we would expect
a student to accomplish in a whole year.
So I wouldn't expect
your student to complete
all of seventh grade math
in the next three weeks.
That seems like a really
big unattainable ask.
And, I'm sorry, what is the second part
of that question again?
I apologize.
- So the question is once,
the first part was do we have
enough to cover the whole school year,
which is the answer is yes,
and the second question is
if their child does complete
kind of the whole grade, all
of eighth grade, for example,
do they automatically
move on to the next level?
- Great.
So students are encouraged
to go to the next level,
however, students have
access to all of the content
at all time.
So if students are working on,
let's say seventh grade
content, and they see
that they are struggling
on particular skills,
they have the opportunity
to go back and look
at the foundational skills
for that in sixth grade,
or fifth grade, and they
can access that content
at any time.
The same thing is true
if you're moving ahead,
so when they finish seventh
grade, they're encouraged
to move to eighth grade.
The program won't force them to do so,
but they're encouraged
to go to eighth grade,
and they could continue
to go to Algebra 1,
and geometry, so they have
access to the entire library
of content at any time anywhere
so that once students complete one thing
they're able to move onto something else,
so they never run out of content to study.
- Yeah.
And just as much as
they can advance forward
if they feel like they need to remediate
something in the past,
they can always look
at last year's content as well
and do that type of review.
So Meaghan, I think we have
time for one more question,
and a lot of parents
are interested in this,
so Jennifer asked, "Is
there a way to follow
"the child's progress remotely?"
- So very important question, and yes.
And so there's a couple
ways you can do that,
but we recommend you
create a parent account,
and then you can link your parent account
to your child's student account,
and you can follow their progress.
So you can know what they're working on,
how much time they're spending on it,
and what progress they're making.
And so for more information on that,
again, while we didn't
cover it in this webinar,
it's included in the slide,
is a link to our parent
Quickstart Guide, and
that will walk you through
how to set up a parent account,
and you can connect that
to your student, or if you
have more than one child,
students, and you're able
to follow their progress
and their learning
experience on Khan Academy.
- Perfect.
Well thank you Meaghan
for sharing your expertise
with our audience, and
then thank you audience
for taking the time out of your
busy evening to be with us.
We know you're extremely busy
during this period of time,
and we really appreciate
you investing your time
into this session.
As we mentioned at the start of this,
if we didn't have time
to answer your questions,
don't worry, we'll follow up
in terms of an FAQ and whatnot.
And if you missed something
and want a review,
we will be posting a
recording of this webinar
as well as the presentation
that you saw here
and make it available online.
For those of you who
registered for this webinar,
you will automatically be
emailed this information.
If you know of other people
who would be interested
in this information, please
go to khanacademy.org,
and you can always share the
links to friends and family
who might be interested as well.
And before we sign off,
I wanted to mention
that we were able to do
this webinar as a result
of some terrific
partners, Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, and Navartis,
who really is stepping up and helping us
make resources like this
available to you all.
And then before we sign
off, we ask one more favor
of you all.
So first, at the end of this presentation,
a pop-up will appear, and
we ask that if you could
provide us with feedback on how to make
future iterations of this
session even better for you all.
And then secondly, we ask
feedback on what kind of sessions
you'd like to hear next.
We created this session
actually as a response
in feedback from our first
high-level presentation
where many of you asked for more specifics
around a schedule, as well
as how to find content,
and so rest assured, we
are definitely listening
to your feedback, and we
definitely want to create
more valuable resources for you,
and we're here to support you.
So in closing, we just wanted to recognize
that you're juggling a lot right now,
both as parents, as educators,
as well as working
adults, and this is really
uncharted territory for all of us.
And so we here at Khan Academy
just want to remind you
to be kind to yourselves.
It's okay to miss one thing or another,
and we're here to help you,
and we just know that you've got this.
So from all of us at Khan Academy,
thanks again, and goodnight.